hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and Alyssa be
crazy and we're gonna watch the trailer
the red band trailer for Hot Tub Time
Machine 2 have you seen the first one I
do you saw the first one it was funny
yeah a lot of sex jokes kind of turned
me off hilarious it turned you on yeah I
was like wow comedy should be much more
witty than sex jokes so hi this is a
high-caliber win that I expect from
myself even I thought it was funny yeah
yeah yeah Craig Robinson was getting
things like that Hollywood yes graphic
nudity four years ago they did in the
past what you word is dick wherever
there is more time so we'll give it more
time we get blackout drunk and wake her
back in time don't mess with a winning
formula
Doritos and poison it's like a tit
Scandinavian gay bar I'll go back to be
done 2024 we met 10 years into the
future you look like a minor Tyler Perry
character
you look like Gandalf the poor you look
like a Zhang's dick which I'm not as
pretty that's fair why are you alone I
think what that means it is killers from
the future we're here to stop your
murder like terminator you think
everything is like terminator cause
everything is like terminator the future
will want to kill you know everyone with
respect in Kaimuki
what is that except more of a super
high-intensity psychotropic drug trip
later yeah I think this may be my house
now
it's a classic alternate reality
situation my fringe take you where you
need to go patriot you guys gotta come
with me why we gonna make America happen
bro no you're not gonna be super welcome
there but we should totally go that
looks like a lot of fun
look I mean I kind of missed the
presence of John Cusack but overall
though it's like like it looks like
they're holding their own pretty well
yeah it looks like a lot of fun it looks
like I think it's a smart direction to
take this equal like instead of going to
the Past the size of the future yeah
like Back to the Future Part 2 so
original it looks like a unique kind of
time travel movie you know I feel like
this Christmas season is gonna be pretty
awesome for the film world yeah Hot Tub
Time Machine 2 we saw with Angelina
Jolie she's directing it I don't know it
just seems like a lot of really good
movies that actually look really amazing
or gonna come out the Christmas season
you named two movies I'm broken yes yes
yes yes
but there's only two movies in Christmas
this one the other one and all some
other ones are coming out at Christmas
time looking forward to but I can't
remember names when you make statements
like that be prepared for someone like
me to come in there and then challenge
you am I wrong
I am not wrong you don't know if you're
wrong
I know for a fact I know two movies
around Christmas both of which look
awesome
so you see a lot of movies that's that's
a going to be a good year or a good
Christmas movie you know what
god you're turning blush so much right
now actual thing that we're doing I'm
gonna see it I'm just really horny now
huh whatever I'll just take my laptop in
the bedroom watch porn
fine no five minutes no I usually takes
my 20 to 30 anyway guys thank you if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe right here and alyssa has her
channel ELISA be crazy she's nuts on
that channel and trust me this girl who
likes and nuts if you know you should
click it go to my channel at this point
in the video we'd like to give some
shout outs cuz we love you yeah and you
asked - Michael Koenig hey you [ __ ]
[ __ ] give me a [ __ ] shoutout
you rock like your accent is because he
knows that I say that all the time
[ __ ] [ __ ] my Boston accent also
my New Jersey accent [ __ ] queer
that's what I hear and the departed all
the time best movie ever
it's not anyway Michael Koenig you're a
frequent comment sir I appreciate the
comments they feel good when they are
read and I feel special and humbled not
really I get a pretty big ego
I am very cocky I mean I've been cocky
since I was a little boy god blessed me
with the best yeah but when he gets an
especially awesome comment he's like
here is regular cocky levelness he was
like here
so true so true it's a michael thanks
for making me cocky I blame it all on
you Isaiah Robinson I love your videos
I've spent like two hours watching them
and could I get a shout-out from Ryan
love you Ryan he specifically asked for
me he did no one ever specifically asks
for me you're very lovable character you
are a character like I have character
traits like you have a big personality
no usually they were saying like I'm
playing a character no you are a
character like like I have care yeah
okay sorry you think about your grammar
is really throws me off I know but is
the way out of the way you said it it's
just the way the sentences put together
it was very misleading I'm sorry I'm
sorry um where were we
Isaiah Robinson the Jewish Isaiah
doesn't matter hell yeah it matters
you can't subscribe for sure no I think
Jewish people are awesome my dad's the
best friend is full of Jewish so um I'm
allowed to say Jews they happen cuz my
daddy was cool with a Jew no I think I
have a Jewish friend I think there's
some Jewish blood in me yeah there's
like a little tiny bit for my dad side I
just really wanted to make sure you guys
knew I am Isaiah back to you if you love
my videos that you get an automatic love
you back from me that's simple that's
simple to find love baby let's do this
right now come on man
come over here find me follow your heart
don't invite people to find you listen I
can invite whoever I want over Michelle
Fernandez come over here I just I think
that's a very bad idea to generally open
that door there's no sex joke thing open
that door oh you like the panties or
thongs it's making sense shut up anyway
sorry that's your shadow Zig
three two - just call me Ziggy share it
read that first hey Ryan
WTF what the [ __ ] does it take to get a
shout-out do I need to blow you cuz I'm
more than welcome to do that hell yeah I
don't care it's not gay if it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] a [ __ ] remember I
taught you that great Channel been sub
since the triple digits eros bio what
eros bio can understand my frustrations
how the hell can you not jerk off on
camera with all these beautiful senorita
things on the channel Sally I would like
to make sweet love to you Ryan you to
bomb Thanks well buddy
Ziggy dude you sound like you're a
confident guy - yeah very confident Z
you know why she's got a big Dickey how
do you gather that what you just read
because who'd be that confidence Adam
big [ __ ] it's a thankful
overcompensating no yes I definitely
don't do that I just AM so big it is
ridiculous that's like three women I've
seen it very special I perhaps choose to
share my penis with only a certain woman
yeah and Ziggy I want to share my penis
with you come over here - let's look at
each other's penises together thanks for
subbing this whole time and trust me I
may not drag off through these girls on
camera but I jerk off to them all the
time when the camera's not rolling so
cool this one I think about her tonight
whatever I see that night that's usually
I'm gonna jerk off to you I can't jerk
off to you I can't masturbate to you you
don't find that flattering comfortable
why is that uncomfortable because that's
my knowledge Rome right how's that gross
you're making me feel like [ __ ] I feel
weird and bad that's usually how I make
girls feel it's weird and bad anyway
sigfigs agree we're done